we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] pet peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be drunk
yeah all righty roo
here we are folks it's uh we might be
drunk you know where you're at
what's shaking fatty you just told me
you watched heartbreak kid but you
didn't tell me what you thought
oh well i've i saw it 20 years ago uh
when i was 16 17 and thought it was
great and then you re-watch it now
it's so good yeah it's so good it's
seinfeld's favorite comedy by the way
really and then when you watch it you're
like oh i get it because the whole movie
is like an episode
you know like oh the girl does this
that's annoying he hates her when she
does this it's all just like little
uh what do you call quirks that are
annoying and the remake was so bad
yeah yeah once they cast mencia in that
movie i was like
that's that was like come on fairly
brothers you're like comedy guys why are
you [ __ ] stabbing me well it is funny
because it's a remake
that's kind of his whole thing but uh
yeah so good grodden's so
subtle so good the woman the wife is so
good she you really hate her
yeah and uh and every guy can this is
like every guy's
thought process like what have i done a
committing i can't do this who is this
bag i can't hang out with her you know
and the grouch thing is so right just
check it out it's 1972
still holds up elaine may wrote it
that's right
no she directed it i think it's a neil
simon
i don't think it's neil where's harry
harry he's fast
let's look it up all right i think it's
a neil i think it's a book
from some other guy and i think neil
simon wrote the screenplay
and then elaine may directed it maybe
you're right damn
and it had a kind of a uh new wave euro
this sucks i looked up the heartbreak
kid the new one comes up that's what
happens the more popular search
brutal brutal the remake ben stiller
i don't know it was a fairly bad you're
right it's neil simon man i'm a dum-dum
that's why it's so good that guy can
write it's funny in the
i typed it into the search on the tv and
it said jew
lenny i was like geez is that necessary
but
that was funny in the search you
wouldn't do that with like black
uh white men can't jump black guy wesley
snipes
but the jew is a civil shepherd too oh
what a dime
hot lovely lady and
and it's kind of insulting too it's like
this obvious [ __ ]
like you know this blonde you know
bombshell versus the uh
the you know annoying new york jewish
gayle
the cons the the constant struggle as a
jewish man yes exactly
the shiksa you like a chick so if you've
dated a jewish girl
oh i could hear your mom snapping a
pencil what did i do
yeah you smothered me now
yeah no no no i mean jews i think we
like women who are a little more
like pushing us away because we tend to
have overbearing mothers
interesting yeah see i think the [ __ ]
the gentile we we try to go [ __ ] our mom
subconsciously and you guys
try to [ __ ] not mom mate i think on some
level you're always [ __ ] a parent
yeah that's true in my last relationship
i tried to [ __ ] my dad it was horrible
she just left yeah
oh yeah we got the big reveal what do
you want you reaching first
me yeah you reached out all right so
this was sam's week so we got the big
weird i went with a summery drink it's
kind of summery out
nothing wrong with that
whoa nice you got a watermelon i got
four different flavors
i'll take a watermelon white claw let's
see what i get
this is exciting mango hey
that might be the worst flavor by the
way i think so all right i'll switch for
something else
[Laughter]
this is great strawberry is that good
that's good all right let's see
i'm a white claw guy i know everybody
calls me a [ __ ]
and a queef but uh you know what i did i
know you like white claw though
i do like i just like it it's
uh it's it's light goes down easy summer
day
oh yeah
that is good it's good it's refreshing
sue me i got a lot of [ __ ] when i was
filming the rooftop thing people were
like like what do you need i was like
mike and amp and uh your friends who
were cool and white claw and they were
like
white claw and then guess what they were
gone always the second
i went for my second round exactly
they're kind of gender neutral
everybody can get on board they're not
too sweet they're not too tart
not too heavy i didn't like the wine
coolers back in the day where it was
like you had to be like a zima
or a mike's hard guy and it was like
mike's heart was really like
classic trying too hard yep yep yep the
sweet you could
you know that you know when you drink a
couple of cokes you feel that your teeth
are kind of
sugary yeah mics would do that so much
sugar
smearing off ice remember that you've
been iced
they would they would just hit it and it
would just start fizzing up and you're
like [ __ ] i gotta check
it out you've been iced dude it's like
the opposite of my ex
when it started coming out she got the
hell out of there but uh and then you
got iced
yeah so did the border
all right here we go folks we're having
too much food
yeah the white claw is kind of i and
unlike the wine cooler
it's not too sweet like i never got the
backlash because it's basically i like
seltzer
this just sells it with a kick exactly
exactly i'm so with you and look i love
beer i'm a big beer guy i grew up
drinking beer
but uh sometimes you know they get that
heavy the yeast the malt the hops it's a
lot in your stomach
well it's hard to have a lot of beers as
you get older oh you're young you do
that i mean [ __ ] i remember all the
times i get drunk off like beer pong
growing up oh
and then you're like pissing all night
you're like oh i had like 14 beers
yeah that's why yeah and we had kegs
every night in in
college and all my friends had like this
weird weird
skinny fat gut you know skinny arms
skinny legs but they had that [ __ ]
distended irish guy belly that's that's
what happens to men
yes it's like you don't work out and you
drink you just kind of get that gut
get that gut just that the you know
african child with the fly by the nose
just that
bubble down there i think it's slightly
different
how'd you get yours alcohol all right
all right
all right it is weird though they don't
eat over there they're they're hungry
but yet they get a gut
isn't that weird it's very small though
i think it's like for air or something
isn't it
is it i don't know i know it's
malnutrition but you think if you didn't
eat
i mean now we're getting dark this is
what the internet needs it's two white
guys
speculating on uh one starving children
you go holocaust
and there's no gut but they were hungry
too
i think they were even more hungry
probably probably and also all the
all the running and all that all this
work oh they work
that's right jesus christ yeah man can
you imagine complaining
all right i mean it's crazy that it's
funny that jews are known from
complaining and then they've like like
they've been literally [ __ ] yeah that's
true that's true
yeah they've done the drafty restaurant
they'll write a full yelp
but then that the worst thing of all
time well there was no hr
in nazi germany which was like can i
speak to someone
right right hr now that's a sketch
the hr guy in auschwitz he was very
rude to me you call these rations good
ah that's great i'm sleeping with eight
other guys on a on a
on a board here like come on one star
star there we go you gotta joke about
that yeah that's right that's right the
jewish uber
damn yeah jews we do
but we complain the way like culturally
jews especially new york jews i think
new yorkers just
also just uh relate by complaining
that's like why pet peeves
is a segment on this you feel you feel
lighter after you [ __ ]
that's true you covet yeah you vent yeah
that's true
you got to get it out and that's why
maybe jews are the therapy kings
because you've mastered the art of of
listening and
deflecting event and blaming our mothers
yeah there you go full circle interest
yeah therapy
oh i blew off a therapy session that i
shouldn't have what
we got adam mckay on paw don't lie so i
had to die
he and i was like do you have something
else and he was like this is all i got
this week and i was like come on
it's like a flight you're like can i can
i change it you know but
the problem with therapy with our guy if
you don't get it in in time
you got to pay for that session oh
really yeah i think he's a 24-hour guy
i'll i'll pay him then damn that sucks
oh well
that's a couple bucks right there for
nothing and i've had it a few times and
i'm like come on i'm so sorry he's like
yeah that's my policy
yeah gotta make sacrifices yeah i know
it yeah you know he blocked off the time
i guess
no for sure no it's he he earned it but
i've done it i've done it too
it happens gotta do it but mckay i mean
that's worth the money it was worth it
he was great it was one of it was
my maybe my favorite episode ever wow
yeah he was
stavros pulled it in man great great
pull the greeks
he's great he's a he knows basketball it
came with jokes that's
guys like that who get that successful i
mean you guys know adam mccabe you know
if you if you can't for some reason
plays adam mckay
then you're not a comedy fan i mean this
is anchor man
step brothers step brothers other guys i
think he had some snl stuff
you wrote the big short what yeah he
wrote that yes
why i think that won best screenplay
yeah
ep for succession what
dude he's literally everything what a
rez
and he was so cool man and now here's
the chicken and the egg question
is he bringing [ __ ] is he prepared
because he's successful or is he
successful because he prepares
definitely
the latter yeah i think so you get to
that level you just he
he came we were stavros and i used to do
bits about like
the all-nba like cuck squad so
we would give like five players who were
the biggest cucks dumb lists
he came with like three of those lists
wow so cool
did he get some knicks in there just to
he he opened by saying like he felt bad
for me because he's like man but he's
like
just be happy he basically said it's
like he opened by saying it's like
a party you haven't been invited to for
so long you're
you're a freshman you got to go to the
senior party even if you don't win you
got to go
yeah you didn't get laid but you got to
go and i was like you know what
i i'm too deranged to look at it in that
manner we're here
and i want it all baby yeah i get it i
get it we all want it all
but uh it's also what makes sports great
it's unpredictable you never know what's
gonna happen and you got to eat the loss
and then when you do win it's that much
better for sure man
i'm i'm blind you watch the heartbreak
kid it feels good when you watch
something that we talk about in the pod
because it's like
it started here and it comes back here i
kind of like it i like it too and
i'm gonna watch rick and morty i'm gonna
make it happen i just
keep forgetting comments i've seen uh
cause that fan base is cult-like yes and
then i don't know what the burping is
whenever i burp they're like you're like
the guy on the show i'm like because
he's a super genius but he burps and
farts all the time oh
interesting okay how are you have a
little rick in you i'll i'll tell you
harry just got here harry don't you
think mark is a little rick in them all
right my dad's name's rick we'll we'll
check it out
i'll check it out everybody loves the
show i haven't heard one like uh
some people we've wrecked some things if
you're like i've seen it's not great
don't listen to sam
and then some people which ones which
ones that you can't remember
uh some movie is said but everybody's
been like no no this is actually
killer their fan base can be a bit
annoying but
the show is great the fan base is a
little bit like in your face
oh really yeah okay hmm yeah
like like simpsons fans like rabid i
don't think simpsons fans are that are
that crazy i think we just i mean look i
er first 10 seasons of the simpsons is
like lights out
untouchable amazing some of the best
comedy writing of all time i still
follow them on instagram
just for the little me too quick scenes
like helpers
yeah i do too what uh give me a peeve
man all right all right this is this
i didn't have a peeve and then this
happened today and i wrote it
down and i can't wait i hope i haven't
done this one before but
somebody text me somebody you don't
really know that well so you're already
like oh this is
this is weird i've talked to this guy in
a while but texts when he goes
hey man can i get so and so his number i
said sure i sent him the number and then
he goes
how are you ah come on i gave you the
number
i'm doing [ __ ] now i gotta have a a back
and forth but he feels guilty about the
number thing
i think so he's like overcompensating
with a how are you
and i know it's harmless and all that
but like is this someone you know well
not that well that's why it's even
weirder because it's like
ah we never really talk but you want to
talk now
or even might not even want to you just
feel like you have to this is
the show has turned into just indirectly
talking [ __ ] about people i know
listeners who are just like that was me
they're just [ __ ] on me
i do worry about that but uh i barely
i've never hung out with the guy let's
just put it that way we're in the same
world
so we have each other's number but you
don't have to do the how are you i get
what you're doing
but you know what else bothers me when
somebody asks for something and they
changed their voice
oh we've talked about we did it all we
did a whole thing the whole thing about
this yeah for sure
yeah just i get it you know what's a fun
fact
asking someone for a favor is actually a
great way to to bond
really because you think oh i'm annoying
this guy but they go oh this person
trusts that i can handle this and
they're close enough feeling to me that
they can ask
so asking for a favor a small favor that
reminds me can i borrow 20 bucks
yeah exactly don't ask for 10 grand from
uh you know seinfeld but
if you just go like can you can you uh
pass me that menu
little things like that they're like oh
and now you're you're you're
bonding hmm you know what bothers me is
when people ask
for like this i guess is maybe more
specific
to our world but i've had like club
people ask me for people's numbers and
i'm like
that's a famous person i can't just give
you their number that's the time
then you're in the position where you're
like i don't want to even text it's
someone i know they won't like
yes so then i'm like do i text this
famous person and be like
hey this uh club owner who used to
underpay me
wants a favor yeah for me for some
reason and then you're like how clueless
are you they'll be like can you ask
joe rogan if he'll do my part i'm like
what do you i wouldn't even know your
podcast like
you want this guy the biggest pot on the
planet like i don't even want to bother
him let alone bother him for your
[ __ ] that's hilarious that's
the favor from the person you don't like
yeah like just the fact that you're
going through me
is already a sign that it's not gonna
happen i'm annoyed
that you're talking to me because now
i'm annoyed right right now i have to
feel annoyed for like two minutes
exactly exactly yeah so get get your
[ __ ] together folks like have some
awareness
he's not gonna do your part that you
know you can see people going
hey you miss all the shots you don't
take and if you don't ask who knows and
all that [ __ ] i'm like ah that's all
[ __ ] you take 400 shots
on me alone why don't you calm down yeah
yeah i'm not a goalie
all right hey start shooting on other
people for a change
that is that's a great point a lot of a
lot of motivational speakers [ __ ]
like
you gotta roll the dice because you
never know it's like sometimes you could
also just be a human and not annoy
people yeah and earn something yourself
instead of trying to just milk some [ __ ]
off other people who've already done
stuff
although you've literally done every
open micros podcast that i've ever
can't say no i don't know how i don't
know you have time i would i wouldn't be
able to write any jokes between doing
this
i do the other podcast i you know i'm
traveling all the time i don't know how
you have time because you always have
new jokes like i wouldn't have any new
bits if i did that
it's tough it's tough i'm i'm that guy i
yeah what's that guy's name the asian dj
with long hair
aoki i mean
hold on that's not my specialty yeah me
neither i hate djs i hate
house music or trance or tech club you
said house music i thought something
else was coming there
hashtag stop dj hate but
i did jim and sam with him once and
hey this guy's brilliant because he's
like the busiest guy on the planet he's
got his own jet he goes from like
switzerland does a show there then he
goes to new york then he goes to
you know copenhagen or whatever and he's
like first of all he's mastered sleeping
anywhere he's like i've learned how to
it's like an ancient chinese art where i
can sleep in a shoe
i'd like to ask him a question he's like
yeah and just the fact that he was on
jim and sam he's like his dad
owns hibachi and his dad invented
hibachi the whole franchise yeah so he
like has his crazy work ethic and he's
the biggest dj on the planet
fascinating guy sweet guy nice guy but
he talked about like his dad cut things
up and now he cut things up
exactly he compartmentalizes his whole
life and where he eats and how he sleeps
and all this he's like you can get a lot
done
while you're [ __ ] or while you're
eating or while you're peeing or while
you're whatever and
i'm forgetting all of it now but it was
really he's brushing his teeth and
jacking off at the same time
man this guy's crazy yeah don't shoot
the toothbrush
you know don't put that on the brush but
yeah so uh really fascinating guy
that there was something interesting
about managing time that well because
i'm jealous
i mean i waste time so much oh i'm so
good at wasting time
i'm the al lubelius have a great joke i
don't know if you know
i love aloe vera great joke writer he's
a bunch of letterman's online but he
didn't talk about like
you know i'm another second closer to
death i'm another second closer to death
i'm another second closer to death time
is killing me time is wasting me i think
that's why i like to do nothing all day
time's not gonna waste me i'm going to
waste time yes
very wordy joke but i like a word smithy
joke but i love
i love jokes like that no me too he's
got some brilliant stuff some real like
brain twisters we're like whoa that's
true that's a great point or whatever
he's he's great he had one too about how
uh he was on a flight with just him and
one other guy the guy was flying the pla
plane and he thought i just realized
i've doubled my chances of dying of a
heart attack
ah because if he gets a heart attack i'm
dead right because i'm fine dying from a
heart attack but his heart attack
oh that's so smart that's like math
jokes
you know he's really i used to watch him
i just worked the door at broadway
comedy club
and you'd see a lot of you know whatever
middle-of-the-road sets come in and he
would come in and bomb a lot but i'd be
yeah damn i'd be like
i'd be watching that guy and just kind
of like marveling at his uh his
structure and his yes
structure completely unique completely
weird but
just trying to work that [ __ ] out is
impressive because how do you
that joke complete is a cool thing but
the the finding the the beats of that
it's got to be a nightmare
yeah you got to do that's all at home
that's that's
what do you call it page to stage you
know some guys
they write a premise they [ __ ] around on
stage and work it out that
you can't really work that [ __ ] out
you're right that's got to be kind of
written first
yeah yeah that which makes even more
impressive to me
yeah he was awesome man that's what's
great about music these guys
i ain't got no banana and then they just
bring it on stage
they don't really go are they i don't
know anything about music so are they on
stage going like hold on cross that out
they didn't like that part
you know because it's just people going
like this in the crowd you know they're
not really reacting the satisfaction
part that's good
yeah yeah that's working
i ain't got no that's no good it must
feel so good to because
i think they just know right like they
just kind of know in the room that the
song is good i would guess
right yes well i mean if you keith
richards and jagger together you've got
that kind of like
unique bond yes where you can just
create [ __ ] together and there must be
moments where they're like
oh we got something oh i know that's
gotta be so cool
like he's on heroin jagger's getting his
dick sucked and they're like this is
great
this is a great song pretty amazing that
like these
random people can find each other and
just make brilliant [ __ ] that the whole
world loves and plays
and changes lives and makes people happy
it's a [ __ ] art did you see that
beatles
uh that beatles headline how they used
to uh they used to jack off together
no there was a whole and it was uh i
think it was ringo starr so that was
before i joined the band
ah i mean beatles indeed
wow i didn't know that i mean i did that
with my friends me too hey
yeah yeah i have a long bit about it now
oh nice yeah yeah
i uh yeah it wasn't uh it's so funny
people are
the two things that would always get
weird at weird reactions from on the
road is that and
saying you know on some level you're
you're trying to [ __ ] your mother
yeah you know it's like and they're like
i'm like is this breaking news i think
this is every therapist
yeah that's freud 101. yeah but i think
it's kid
jerking your kids so that's weird and
then it's
incest i guess so it's only the most
popular porn category of all time
good point good point where is porn
gonna go
oh good i mean animals i don't know it's
a good question
it might be next it might be next
there's nothing left we've done family
members we've done interracial we've
done old and young we've done
how it keep that's what taboo is it's
like the way a joke is you go up to the
line and keep crossing it yeah that's
where jokes keep getting more offensive
right where is where's porn gonna be
i know we've done food we've done it all
we've done like inanimate objects and
stuff
it's gonna be like guy [ __ ] horse but
then like the next and that's gonna be
[ __ ] up and then the next one is gonna
be like
guy [ __ ] uh horse step horse or
something like that
they're gonna have to keep going darker
yeah guy [ __ ] horse guy [ __ ] black
horse
zebra guy [ __ ] yeah yeah stolen [ __ ]
gay or gay ancestors like oh my god
right
gay excess horse that's hilarious horse
discipline
just pissed on that horse ah yeah the
horse seemed to like it
right oh the horse ain't complaining
horses have bad lives man i know they
really do well i guess it depends we
talked about
dogs but horses you're either like a
race racehorse that's like pro
athlete so in the horse world being a
pro athlete
is the worst you're getting whipped
you're the star
yeah but you're getting nothing that's
interesting yeah even if you
if you break a leg they shoot you yeah
horrible holy [ __ ]
nba you break a leg rehab come back in a
year you still get paid still get paid
i think you got a bid here maybe write
it down harry
interesting that's a great point yeah
the the dogs
have jobs drug sniffing seeing eye
anxiety dog police dog the dalmatian on
the fire truck
that sucks but at least if they suck at
it they just get to live with some
family right you know the horse is like
yeah we gotta shoot you in the head
you you blew out an ankle there uh
secretariat or whatever have you ever
been to the racetrack the horse trainer
i love a racetrack fun oh yeah i grew up
going to that [ __ ]
i love it man yeah and it's just a
reason to drink and be outside and wear
a
seersucker suit and mint julep
a guy i went to high school with the
toughest guy i know this guy ron
he would get into fist fights all the
time he's a head butt guy
i know i know he was the funniest guy
coolest guy
all the girls loved him and he would
just get in a [ __ ] with a guy and just
go
and the guy's nose exploded we're like
oh [ __ ] it's on
you know and then the place would go
nuts but uh he now does the uh
i guess like the grooming of horses like
he works at the stables
damn makes a fortune living the good
life he's like the most new orleans guy
on the planet he's drinking a mint jewel
up right now
that's my horse he
headbutts the horse he lost the race
yeah
headbutt is so it's so violent that is
savage
because you're hurting yourself it's
almost like a half kamikaze yes
that's great you're kind of like you're
hurting yourself and you're
but you're hurting them more you're
hurting them more but still that's how
tough i am like i'm willing to hurt
myself just so you get hurt
and no one sees it coming headbutt is
always like
one of my favorite scenes happy gilmore
when he headbus bob barker
it's so violent to do it to an old man
is [ __ ] hilarious it's crazy have you
ever headbutted someone
i don't know i think so i did it on
accident and i
i think there's a way to do it right
obviously because people do it and then
move on and keep walking but like ah it
is the worst pain it's that
skull on skull [ __ ] your brain shakes
up it's just horrible i think i did it
like friends drunk and i was like yeah
this doesn't feel good
yeah i had that one friend who was just
crazy he was like the dude you're like
this dude
he didn't look tough yes that was the
worst part of it where like this guy
does not look
tough yep and he would be the first one
to throw down and be like this dude is
like
it's not just being physically strong
it's kind of like not
shying away from being hit which i don't
have right
certain people just have that thing when
other people come at you they just are
like calm as hell
yes yes and that's like that's another
thing that is very interesting that's
like what a mayweather type has where
it's like yeah he's
great at dodging he's just calm right
right it's almost this race car gene
where
when when you're in a crazy moment your
your adrenaline is lower your heartbeat
is lower your heart rate is lower where
we go the other way
oh i yeah i panic for sure yeah but also
i panic because i'm self-aware and i
know i can't fight
right right yeah you ever really lost
one
you ever gotten your ass kicked big time
by the kid who
was like the protector of us oh really
yeah he
beat the [ __ ] out of me once wow we were
both
drunk and he it just turned into like me
thinking i was tougher than i was and
him knowing i wasn't wow and i think it
just kind of started with like the
poking and then it turned into like a
thing
and i remember him taking my face and
smashing it on the floor and i was just
like
i just came too bloody i'm like yeah he
got me pretty good jesus
what does this guy do is he like a
marriage counselor like what does this
guy do he works in hr at a concentration
camp
perfect you missed that callback uh
wow what does he do now i don't know he
was actually the weirdest thing is the
nicest guy
of course they always are yeah i mean i
just crossed him the wrong way and it's
funny to call a guy who did that to me
then but he's really like the nicest guy
i get it i get it yeah yeah i remember
one guy this is crazy one guy [ __ ] with
them hard like a tough guy
at a party and we got into it and he
[ __ ] keyed the guy in the neck and
sent him to the hospital and i was like
heed
yeah what yeah he was guy a prison vet
like who is this guy he was pretty
fearless i remember he pulled a gun on
me once in his apartment
and like he did it as like a joke i'm
funny i just got the guy's like the
nicest
guy yeah but he like cocked the gun in
my face as i was like taking food out of
his freezer and i was just like
that's hilarious i was like uh he was
like gotcha and i was like
yeah i mean you got me i will not eat
these pizza rolls
that worked for all the people that are
like i need to protect my home
like those people that are just like
check this [ __ ] out yeah i had that
friend too there
i had two guys with guns they're both
firemen now just crazy like
beefy white guys football team and uh
one time they came to my house
they knock on the door it's like a
tuesday at 10 p.m my mom's in a
like you know pajamas and my dad's like
holding a candle with a night hat you
know and they're like where is mark home
and i'm like
i'm on the stairwell like hey what are
you what do you what's going on guys
like oh can we talk to you and i was
like okay my mom's like what's going on
you know that whole thing i'm like i got
it go to sleep you crazy [ __ ]
and i go outside and uh
they're like hey you want to come
drinking i'm like dude it's tuesday
we're we're
juniors in high school and he goes
you're coming out they pulled a gun and
i was like
i guess we're going out and i just went
out like flip-flops and uh shorts and a
t-shirt we went drinking all night
jesus i didn't want to but you know we
didn't when a guy's got a gun
you just do it it would be great if you
took it even further
where are you going shut up [ __ ] get
down yeah right
and then hey mr norman suck my dick he's
like okay
okay don't shoot yeah
wild wild guys guns yeah
guns they just went out that my thing is
like
wouldn't you be scared that you just get
like you act that reckless
and you're drunk and [ __ ] that a cop
grabs you and is like what the [ __ ] is
this and then you're really
yeah but i guess if you're willing to
pull that joke with a gun
right you're not thinking about
consequences probably i guess not yeah
and they were those kind of guys like i
i hope someone [ __ ] with us which i
don't i just want to get drunk and have
fun and laugh but they were like those
types that's not healthy
no these guys these guys like their dad
hit them they had some stuff everyone's
got friends like that growing up but
they're like let's start some [ __ ] and
i'm like oh we're having a good night
yeah i never thought like wouldn't this
night be cooler if i lost a tooth
i know i know exactly yeah like fights
are so unpredictable like you never know
first of all some guy you're finding
could be some mma psycho especially
now especially now yeah most people like
they just knew a couple things like
boxing was the big thing no one followed
ufc back then no
no not at all i was the only new ufc
because of like pro wrestling back then
i knew like ken
shamrock oh yeah because he was in the
wwf i only
but like no one knew boxing was a thing
but then
i've seen [ __ ] in like the little side
where people like some guys start [ __ ]
with a guy who knows how to fight
that ain't good no that's bad news and
uh
yeah we i was in green point one night
and those polish guys
are [ __ ] tough as nails and there's
stomping a guy
out and you're like okay well he's
clearly dead then he gets up and then he
starts winning you're like how is that
guy not dead
you know tell another polish joke
i know right your sausage sucks
oh crazy any group has it's i mean like
no one wants to [ __ ] with albanians no
colin quinn at that joke in his special
like he oh we go through every group and
he goes and to show you how tough
albanians are i'm not even gonna do an
albanian show
and i was like [ __ ] i knew a couple
albanian guys you're like these are
scary dudes
really of course i don't even think
about albanian guys
russian black white italian they're like
all
all albanian guys are like
schwarzenegger and t2 oh no robert
patrick and t2
oh you just shoot them and they just
like keep walking to you
t-1000 yeah yeah yeah that guy was
terrifying
[ __ ] great in the sopranos though
yeah he was great
gender a gambler yes my favorite scene
is when he when he
uh he loses all this money to tony and
then he
he goes to his son oh hell yeah come on
no mango
black guy damn it's only fair
all right i'm gonna have to take this
mango well uh
yeah and he goes no off-roading uh-huh
he's like i told you not to get mud on
the tires and then he just takes his
son's car to
meadow soprano yes yes the darkest [ __ ]
your dad just stole your car
so dude you gave it to the girl you like
oh my god that's perfect such a dark
oh that's one of the best and when he's
talking to tony like we have all this
history and he's like this is what i do
right pray on the [ __ ] week
oh man what a great show
yeah boy give me a break guys it's been
a few weeks since i did a sopranos
reference
i'm sorry no that was a good one deep
cut
do we have an ad [ __ ] mango i don't
know if we do
ah yeah you got the mango you got the
[ __ ] stick
is mango really bad i just don't i mean
you might like it i just don't
what's the what's your number one white
claw i like black cherry so this worked
out
blackberry black cherry oh blackberry oh
[ __ ] i've been too drunk every time i
had one i was like oh i love black
cherry yeah i think it's great this is
my favorite one
see what i got lime is the ultimate
worst so we have no lime
is meh lime is bad with every like bud
light lime sucks
all those lime ones but then a margarita
is great and then a lime and your
tequila's great
so
you know i like like those lacroix
seltzers and i like like peach pear i
like
plain i like i'm always down for a black
cherry cell too
but [ __ ] lime is just kind of bland
yeah
it's banana's similar i love a banana
but a banana flavor
of anything i'm like ugh depends banana
hi-chew is pretty good
what's that you never had those little
hijus those like gummy candies or mad
good
oh no i don't know hai chew i was once
in a i was once like late at night in a
korean grocery with ari shafir jeff ross
and david tell
and dave and jeff are just like snacking
on candies
and you know they're like they don't
really party i mean i guess jeff will
drink but like
yeah it is like years ago and dave
doesn't drink anymore so he's just like
eating candies and he's like this one
gives you the best sugar high it's like
hilarious
people that are sober like get like yeah
get a buzz off sugar right
i've never seen dave attell eat have you
ever had
a couple times really yeah well we you
were at the
one time at keynes he ate with us
remember oh yeah i just can't imagine
him
cutting a piece of meat and putting in
his mouth it's just so foreign we were
once driving back from a road gig and
stopped at a
this is like what do you expect dave to
eat he stopped at a uh
gas station and got like a sausage
biscuit it was just like i'm just on the
side of the road
you expect dave's diet to be like
sausage like all manly
right exactly like truck stop food
yeah he's like the manliest guy and a
road dog so of course he's eating
you know horrible gas station [ __ ]
ugh just bacon and like fried eggs
that's all you expected to tell me
he feels like a guy in the 50s you know
i like whiskey cocaine
eggs and bacon [ __ ]
did you ever say your peeve my peeve oh
okay i got one for you
people that try to plan things with me
far out oh
it's not just for me it's like a thing
with adhd
add whatever you want to call it you
don't like to plan far out it's very
it's very stressful for you like what
are you doing three weeks from today
i'm just like oh that's tough i i was
reading about it so i'm like why is this
so stressful for me it's it's that we
need instant reward we need something
we're like
we're like [ __ ] like give me a treat
yeah you're like how about this
what are you doing three weeks from now
i'll give you a hand job and then maybe
i'm like all right i'm in right right
something it's never a good thing either
it's always like a wedding or a
you know some kind of like a gig great
i'll do a gig three weeks
it's never what do you what are you
doing three weeks from today yankees
behind home plate what are you ever it's
never that it's always like
i need help moving exactly exactly just
like all right
or some [ __ ] that you don't want to go
to over 30
hire a [ __ ] mover ah jesus i know
good lord
that's crazy i used to move furniture
and i'm i'm agreeing i did it a few
times and it was
horrible it's tough it's my frame is not
conducive for that
yeah you're six twelve you got uh
hairy chest yeah you you shouldn't be
moving the hairiness after doing it i
don't know i tried
i was trying to think of something about
you but not be insulting
yeah yeah you shouldn't be moving yeah
you're a human uh you're like the guy
outside of the car you know i used to
have that job i would just do this
yeah but uh yeah moving furniture sucks
but what
we oh yeah the three weeks thing i don't
know where i'm gonna be who knows what
kind of psycho is like oh in three weeks
i'll be at uh costco who the [ __ ] knows
where they're gonna be
it's it's stress it stresses me out even
if it were good it stresses me out
usually but here's the devil's advocate
yeah what if the guy says
look i'm getting married in eight months
just put it in the calendar now
and don't take any gigs that day and
then
we're cool and i'm like okay i actually
appreciate it don't act like that
doesn't annoy you
it does i know that annoys me i don't
want to go to a wedding but at least you
give me a heads up
i got one for you how about a [ __ ]
sunday night wedding so i don't have to
miss a weekend no i want that i don't
know i'm with you because it's always
hey it's saturday night
in miami you got to take two flights of
the boat like come on
it's on a little island yes exactly you
have to answer a riddle
right right yeah and then and then
pay for a uh yeah a ridiculous spa
yeah exactly weddings are wack sunday
night it would be nice
or like late afternoon yeah hell give me
weddings are tough give me a tuesday
wedding and i get it it's
because for a lot of people we have
comedy the wedding is their thing yeah
this is their big moment this is a big
night big event
so i get it but it's tough it is tough i
never get comics who want to have a huge
wedding because it's like we get
we get that kind of attention too much
right
right yeah i would never want a big
wedding no no but i think even if i
weren't a comic i wouldn't
yeah but did you go to quinn's wedding
colin quinn no did you i didn't go
either i was crushed
but uh you go to giannis's no i didn't
go either okay
[ __ ] who got married i went to joe's
list i went to joe listen okay
that was fun pretty big for a wedding
yeah that was fun but it was fun that
was a great
time great group great group that's the
key i think we were the same table
yes that's right that's right and uh
ryan hamilton can
he can cut up a dance floor yeah i went
to rachel feinstein's wedding which
tom papa officiated oh the great tom
papa
that's fine and quinn gave a great
speech at it oh nice that was fun that's
a lot of pressure though it's all comics
brutal
brutal gig you got it is funny where
you're like man
at a regular wedding the hack [ __ ] kills
at a comics wedding
you gotta go a little ulti you gotta
yeah you gotta
play to the back of the room but
quinn a big genius huge fan
he's the he's the best at that he's
better to the back of the room
i think true and also you need it's so
hard because
at a comic wedding you kind of have to
walk the line between
a hint of hack just to get the other
people
get the family but then also be so
unique like
tom pop is so good at that because he's
so he's so good at working like any room
yes he's a pro and uh yeah i remember he
went on after quinn was like
no no quinn went on after tom papa and
said man your minister energy's really
bugging me and it got a huge laugh
and tom papa came back out and said yeah
you know i should have mumbled like you
through my speech that was much better
and it killed and it was like
like two guys like off the cuff roasting
each other like you don't see that at
weddings
most speeches at weddings are terrible
terrible time or when they met
and they got hooked up and it was a
beautiful thing
and the soul mate yeah yeah yeah yeah
stacy i remember
back in high school you were always
a bit of a [ __ ] yeah exactly no
there's always the [ __ ] system roaster
right right yeah when we first met john
we hated him we thought he was gay
yadda yadda you're like john's like
jesus christ
we thought he probably did a limp dick
he had a dumb haircut and his face
wasn't really doing much for us
yeah but now we see how much you like
him
right and the whole family's on board
yeah there's always that one person goes
too far you guys are cute together but
i can't wait for the divorce we all know
what's happening
yeah but uh i've had people email me and
go like hey
i'm a fan of comedy i like your stuff
can you help me with a wedding roast and
i'm like i
i appreciate it it's flattering but i
can't because i don't know them
yeah you know it really has to it really
has to have
your imprint on it you can't really get
someone i guess you get someone to punch
it up
sure that's what they want but i'm like
this is like a gig now you're asking me
to do work oh they're not going to pay
you
i don't think so they're just like hey
can you help me out here i don't know
you but were you right for me
yeah yeah exactly that's that's work
it's work i should be like hey can you
help me put a deck on my house
you know for free just to you know throw
it back at them
it's [ __ ] crazy you got a wreck i
don't know
his claws are hitting me i don't know
how much how far in we are here
really yeah these clothes are hidden you
didn't eat before i oh
let's see what i might have another i
might have i don't know if i have a
wreck but i definitely have another
piece oh give me another peeve i love a
peeve
all right needless worry
needless worry people who worry when you
don't need a word ah
yes like my mom does this to me where
she just panics and i'm just like hey
if it's not okay it's just not gonna be
okay right
i worry but like she she'll worry for me
like in ways where i'm like
hey guess what you raised me i worry
yeah it's not like i'm not nervous
you're right when your mom is nervous
all the time
of course you you you absorb a lot of
that i yeah so
it's literally like she's a sponge of
worry and it's just
all over me i'm like yeah i got some
worry i mean now yeah of course of
course but i'll be on the road she's
like
you know you're careful when you're
vaccinated i'm like no i actually i got
unvaccinated
last week walgreens does that now right
right
yeah they took the fiser out of me yeah
yeah come on mom
no she's just worried i mean look i get
it we do we have jobs that are like
look i i really love my job but like it
it can be a little draining so i think
they worry like oh you're never getting
sleep you're
sure we're drinking we're flying no i
get it i mean i have a cat
and look it's a cat it doesn't talk and
we we don't really relate that much but
sometimes i'm like there's a cat chewing
on
is a cat choking and i freaking out a
little bit and i'm like ah the cat's
just hanging out it's eating a
piece of yarn or whatever but in my mind
i'm like it's a cat show should i give
it a heimlich ah you know should i call
the vet
and i can't even imagine a kid i would
[ __ ] blood every day this is a cat
yeah no i remember i used to have a cat
and i was the same [ __ ] he'd be like
yeah what do we do what are we doing you
kind of have that panic hit you like
well uh i don't want to die on my watch
i'm a shitty
cat owner what am i doing you're
watching a pet suffer that's why it's
got to be like hard to see a kid going
oh
right like if your kids going through
[ __ ] at school or something yeah getting
bullied you're like that must be
hell salaccus i don't i don't know if
this is too
personal but he was telling me i'm glad
you said his name i know someone
the cues he was telling me some [ __ ] his
kid's going through and i was like
ah i was crushed and i'm like you're the
dad i can't even remember what you're
going through
oh man like that's one of the things we
were like how do you not
if your kids get in [ __ ] with the school
how do you not like knock on the door
and beat the [ __ ] out of the eye
i know dude one time i was in i don't
know i was like
12 and i was at a friend's house and my
friend got into a fight with this other
kid in the neighborhood like a you know
a dumb fist fight with two boys
no one you know just crazy swinging and
the other kid hit my friend got a good
one on him and his glasses flew off
but right when he hit him my friend's
dad
happened to open the door and saw his
son
getting punched in the face by this
other kid and the glasses flew and they
skidded on the concrete and he goes
your ass is grass and the other kid went
ah
and ran away as a kid does because
and so then the dad runs out he's like
okay what the [ __ ] who is that kid i'll
kill him
and i i remember like jesus dad's a
little psycho but he just was
he saw his kicking punched out i don't
know and the glasses are very expensive
apparently he just we're like like it
ended there the dad [ __ ] kicks
through the door and his home just
starts [ __ ] wailing on him
yeah yeah it's crazy that dad
angry i'm you always hear these old
stories of like you ever hear about the
dads who like okay
you two boys have a problem you're gonna
fight on the front lawn i'm going to
have a beer and sit in the lawns
hamilton i've i've heard about this
happening i've never seen it but i had
friends who were like oh yeah my dad had
to watch me fight another kid
just to settle it i don't know that is
like the modern day duel kind of like it
is
after school yeah it's uh it's gotten
softer it has it has
in 20 years it'll be i challenge you to
a debate right
right yeah we're going to tweet off yeah
but uh
jake lamotta famous boxer the the raging
bull
he said in his book that this is the
bronx and you know the
20s or whatever this is uh
sybil shepard again right oh no that was
what's her name the other blonde woman
yeah beautiful blonde forgot her name
but
he said his dad all the dads would get
in the neighborhood and
sit in a circle and then they would
throw pennies at their sons while they
fought and whoever won got to pick up
the pennies and that was just
entertainment for the deads
and so jake lomato got good doing that
they were like six
crazy those are different times back
then he took a dive
and he didn't get the pennies but he got
a bunch of extra money right here
right he got a nickel on the side yeah
fun store
bam yeah lamont i mean that was just
such a tough
that was also when italians were like
treated
horrifically so they just had to make
fun amongst themselves you know
every group's gone through [ __ ] man i
know every group in this country has
gone through some [ __ ]
yeah sinatra's dead had to change the
name of his bar to oh
hurleys or o'hanley's or whatever just
because they were like you can't have an
italian
bar what are you crazy so he had to
change to an irish name
damn crazy to think about italians like
hoboken was in
hoboken yeah damn yeah yeah good
documentary
man sinatra's life was bonkers crazy
life and he was a manic depressive i
think
i think so yeah yeah damn what a life
all the girls that he was [ __ ] would
say he would just be like
ah it's 2 a.m they're like i'm gonna go
home he's like what are you kidding
let's fly to london he had a jet
so they would just fly to london they're
like the girl's like this is brutal i'm
dying here
come fly with me was like a status thing
it was
it totally was yeah sinatra [ __ ]
everyone oh he really
uh did not seem like a great person
though
no i think he was a piece of [ __ ] and uh
mob ties and another great phil hartman
character on essence oh
man so good so good smoking
yeah hated elvis right because elvis was
the new
hot guy and he's like i was the hot guy
but you know the changing of the guard
it's it's
he got the last laugh he had a longer
life and career and [ __ ] that's true but
sinatra had that
rise and then he kind of just fell down
and came back
because of from here to eternity right
it's just so weird that acting is what
brought sinatra back
yeah that's cause he's not that good an
actor not great not great
yeah but he's but he was good and you
know he's good enough but
man he was a [ __ ] his second half was
just it was so much cooler when he was
just older
i know he was kind of like the like he
was almost like bieber-esque when he was
young
exactly he was like just the hot guy who
was like women are like oh and then he
gets
older and he kind of was like grizzled
and cooler and yeah
got drunk all the time yes exactly you
got the white face
yeah yeah a little more vulnerable and
he would do like the reagan
he did the reagan uh what it was that
was that big circular
stage rickles did it what do you call
that the presidential thing
where they all perform oh [ __ ] i don't
know correspondence dinner
is that what it was it was something
like it was a inauguration
maybe maybe it was one of those it was a
big thing with the president and
reagan's in the front row and rickles
roasts him and it's [ __ ] hilarious oh
i remember that i remember the clip of
that yeah and then sinatra closed it out
it was like
this unbelievable performance you know
every hilarious they roasted a president
but they did it like a comedy central
roast
yeah where they're like i mean this guy
he [ __ ] uh you know like trump this
guy raped someone everyone's like
i mean they did roast trump they did
roast imagine but yeah but like
holy [ __ ] i know we had no idea you ever
see the story
where uh artie lang has it
i think he told this story on seth
meyers or something but uh
artie lange is telling the story about
how he roasted donald trump
and it's a clip it's already
howard stern and donald trump and trump
is on it whoa and trump is like man i
gotta say like already set of the night
no one killed harder than ardy and then
artie does one of the jokes about
it was something about his daughter yeah
he just tells it in front of howard and
howard laughs something about you know
your own uh
you see the name on this casino you'll
own this casino and he's like oh your
name is borgata instead of trump that
was like the joke you know
and and then trump hears it and goes i
already just bombed
he bombed the show he didn't get any
laughs he was terrible wow
just watching him turn like you're like
oh [ __ ] any time he feels like
burns at all he slips he just changes
reality
wow that's him in a nutshell that's his
whole presidential
career that's fascinating nice little
window into his whole
personality it's weird when dudes like
that get roasted
yeah because they have so much but you
the little things you you can't make
jokes about this
yeah the ego man the ego wins i think
the shatner roast they were like you
can't make any comments about
his wife that he may be murdered right
which is such a funny note
like he might be he might be a murderer
let's just keep it about his hair
and or appearance star trek jokes please
nothing about the murder yeah we might
roast oj one day who knows i mean he's
back in the limelight but it's gonna be
like hey nothing about nicole
no glove jokes you know that could
happen dude
it just shows can you imagine oj great
football player
that's the rose that's the rose this guy
yeah it wasn't too funny in those naked
gun movies though
horrible actor yeah that's true it could
happen
those hertz commercials oj you really uh
you're really stunk
one thing you didn't kill those herd
commercials something like that and
they're like
oof don't do this too close yeah have
you seen that documentary on oj that uh
no oh it's on uh 30 30 it's like a
six-part or something
that might be one of the best
documentaries of all time about the the
whole thing with the trial
i think it was ezra edelman who's like
just one of the great
documentary makers period harry you've
seen it right
it's incredible wow it's like six parts
it's the mo one of the most american
things ever made because it like
captures
the rise and fall murder so you have
like
the true crime element the the heroic
athlete
the come from nothing the american dream
yeah the racial element right
the riots like it's like literally
everything that could have
tremendous stakes wow yeah and it's just
heartbreaking it's a heartbreaking
and then like the pressure from his
people like he wasn't one of the guys
like in the 60s all these black athletes
sacrificed some wealth to be part of
this movement like
muhammad ali bill russell yeah all these
guys and he was like
uh you know his famous land i'm not
black i'm oj so it's kind of like
it's unfair to put that kind of pressure
on a kid to be like
do this but at the same time it is it's
got looking back it's gotta hurt
yeah wow man it's got so much it's
one of the most brilliant documentaries
that's i think as highly as i can wreck
anything and
that's a wreck folks that's as high it's
it's just i mean the 30 for 30s
they're great they're masterpieces
they're so good i'm not even a huge
sports guy and i'm i'm loving every
minute of it because i like documentary
and they're so well done the one on
paul daly is that his name he's that
rednecky hick
golfer john daly john daly that one is
amazing
he's a drunk right he's a huge drunk i
mean it's basically happy gilmore
but real and he's [ __ ] fat as [ __ ]
now and he's still good right still good
and he would whack the [ __ ] out of it
and he was like this degenerate guy and
everybody's in like a polo
tucked in with pink pants and he's like
what are you doing he's got a mullet and
everything
i got a budweiser oh it's great great 30
for 30. i have them on delta flights now
which is great oh
that is nice get a little in between a
little beat bobby flay you throw one of
those on yeah
god you gotta love delta by the way just
a side note
that's a good app but uh but
um i mean you wouldn't know for matt's
reactions but right now
no i've seen him crack a guy okay he's a
tough nut
but uh oh there we go we gotta i saw
some teeth
um matt's like the guy in the front row
whatever my show of mine
but uh
but uh oh so this guy is a fan of our
pod
and he bumped into me at a show and he
goes hey man i'm a firefighter i love we
might be drunk i like to drink but i get
all these free
uh united things because i don't know
he's a firefighter they get
benefits or whatever so he gave me a
stack of united drink
tickets or vouchers that's amazing given
to mackie of course he's got status with
united
[ __ ] airline i know i know i'm a
delta guy but
well united it's like remember when they
like had that guy dragging and
screaming off the flight and then like a
week later they're like they killed a
dog
so you can't make up worse press than
dragging an asian man off the flight
followed by a week later you just take a
dog and you're like you're stuffing him
in the overhead you're like
you put a living thing in a place with
no oxygen i know
i know i love the idea of the that's my
anxiety dog and the dog's like
i'm in an overhead compartment for nine
hours what are you doing to me
um but yeah so my point is he got me a
lounge pass now all i want out of life
is to get in that lounge i don't care
about hbo special
hollywood movies get me in that lounge
it's so easy to get in the delta lounge
yeah you get the card with the lounge
access it's like an extra like 400 bucks
a year it's so worth it
oh think about all the coffee and free
first off
free food food booze booze great hang it
yeah
you're really crazy to not figure that
out i want to get i want to earn it
you can get it with the credit card i
know i don't use credit
what did you ever use credit what are
you a [ __ ] drug mule i don't usually
trust credit i don't like it i don't
like owing stuff you don't
wait so you only pay incre in debit
debit i
i have money in my account you're
[ __ ] out of your mind i don't like
credit i don't understand it it's fake
money but i'm gonna pay back later and
then it does now there's a link you paid
at the end of the month there's no late
fee if you pay it on time
i won't i won't pay it i don't trust
myself
just set up autopay what are you [ __ ]
crazy that's not bad
what wait this is insanity you got to
set up autop i don't know how to set up
autopay that's going to take you you
want the podcast producer to set up your
credit card please
this would be i would love if harry just
robbed you blind that would be
the best way to lose all your money i
cannot
do anything with a password with an
account no i'm incompetent
but the fact that you're against credit
is [ __ ]
incredible i don't like credit mark you
understand you get perks with the credit
cards
that don't that that's a myth oh i get
paid
one of these points what are these
points i have a delta card i get
[ __ ] free stuff all the time really
and i get the lounge
you get the last yes what i thought only
kings and sultans and
uh you know athletes you need to figure
this out
i thought the lounge was reserved for uh
you know
the the royalty like prince harry's
getting in there
there's a lot of schlubs in that lounge
really you gotta get the lounge is
beautiful
well i did get in because i got the pass
from this fireman thank you sir
eric uh it was great i mean i was at hog
heaven i
i didn't want to take the flight because
i had this big giant bark lounger i'm
eating 30 eggs i'm like
cool and luke in there i had nine bloody
marys you got into a fight with a bigger
guy in the lounge
yeah exactly i'm putting muffins in my
pocket
it was the best day of my life dude cool
and luke's a [ __ ] great oh
one of the newman [ __ ] rules rule
who's cooler than paul newman very few
and divorced and then actually met his
the woman he was supposed to be with his
what the hell's his wife the second wife
she was an actress actress
cool there's all these videos on youtube
of her busting his balls and he's like
ah and they're the coolest couple but
yeah and he always said why go after
he's the guy who did the
quote why go out for a burger when he
got a steak at home exactly
yeah yeah women jerk off to that [ __ ]
yeah women like being compared to meat
yeah well as long as you're faithful as
long as your faith yeah he was
paul a man i had just seen slap shot
like maybe six months ago
for the first time because dana gould
was like you've never seen one of the
best flap shots sports comedy
dude it's hilarious it's some of the
lines you're like this is
politically correct for the incorrect
for then for the 70s like the 70s
this is [ __ ] shocking i know but it's
hilarious
so funny it's actually a good movie too
and funny
it's great yeah the idea of like a minor
league team that just gets [ __ ] up
and has really only wins because they're
dirty
and you're rooting for them is is just
perfect
yeah complete underdog story so fun
ragtag
but also he's interesting because he was
the one of the biggest actors ever
great actor handsome guy cool guy
found auto racing like in the back half
of his
life and then just was like i only act
to do this
now wow yeah which is it kind of has
this comedy thing where you're like he's
obsessed with it
he wants to get good at it and he's it's
like oh you know
sometimes you hear about these like
lawyers like geraldo like i was a lawyer
i was a valedictorian of my college all
this but
i want to do comedy and so you you keep
doing law just to
support the comedy but you don't hear it
the other way around
like we did the acting to do this yeah
that's true i mean
paul newman it's crazy the span of his
career because there's some movies that
are kind of underrated of his like
hud is underrated oh hud is great but
but my favorite paul newman movie
i feel like it doesn't get the shine it
deserves it's the verdict
oh the alcoholic yeah [ __ ] brilliant
i haven't seen that david mammoth dude
yeah really really dark and good rewatch
that now that's it
i'm gonna rewatch it man that's one of
my favorites great movie i mean uh the
hustler
incredible jackie gleason gleason yeah
minnesota fats
yes best name of all time it is one and
also just the idea of like
a pool shark like yeah what a cool
loungy and dark yes
boozy and the fact that like you you
have to like pace your drinking for your
job is hilarious it's kind of like
comedy
it is yeah and then the uh the color of
money which is kind of a weird
he's so good in there young tom cruise
what's that that lady was hot
we're leaving out butch cassidy we're
leaving out the sting is great
sting is great yeah yeah but his career
wrote to perdition
oh yeah right great movie tom hanks is a
badass
no one talks about that movie jude laws
in that he's like the villain yeah
remember chris rock at the oscars jude
law
he's in every movie jude law he goes
even the movies he's not in
cupcakes by jude law special thanks and
then tom
uh sean penn came out and was like sean
was like
jude law is one of our finest actors
yeah
man actors are stiff oh they're the
worst that's why i respect the auto
racing because i'm like yeah
acting come on get out of here yeah it's
cool i mean i love movies but like just
don't take it like we're [ __ ] comics
don't take yourself so seriously
i love uh i love how gervais would just
go so hard
oh the best the best so fun that's like
a dying thing too what he's doing so
it's fun to watch him do it in real time
i mean look at oscars and all that [ __ ]
it's it's all in the toilet now it feels
like
golden globes didn't even happen it's
just so pretentious the idea of like the
red carpet and like
who are you wearing it's like you know
what dude of course
la is such an out of touch bubble
already and then you throw this [ __ ] on
top of it
exactly exactly they think they're
helping
and we got to do the red carpet before
the oscars and they all
cry up there and talk about it we have
to help people i'm like you're
uh you're you're wearing a ten thousand
dollar dress and you just accepted a
gold trophy for playing make-believe
and you want us to listen to you you
[ __ ] choose and you're talking about
nuclear proliferation on stage
shut the [ __ ] up it's unbelievable it's
like uh
i mean that's why gervais was so
brilliant i remember when he said like
you're all talking about like save these
people save that people
you you're working for amazon ah i mean
that was like one of the best lines i
was like ooh
that's that's cutting because yeah like
look i get it we all got to work
sure but having that just that just the
pomposity to
go up there yes that's why comedy is so
great because you we at least get to
keep it real at least we're you know
sure we're doing the funny bone in
poughkeepsie with the
chicken wings and all that [ __ ] but like
at least we're being honest and
and uh and truthful somewhat
it's hard to be super integrity it's
hard yeah it's hard to be really
cocky up there if you're eating wings
it is in the crowd but it keeps us not
pretentious
they should serve wings at the [ __ ]
golden globes because that way
it'd be hard to be if you if you're
wiping your fingers with a moist
towelette maybe you'd
be like we should calm down yeah exactly
give him a check spot
i want a check spot at the oscars
jennifer lawrence is bombing why does
she
oh everyone's paying their bill that's
why exactly
try that [ __ ] for for 10 minutes uh wait
i had to
oh gervais my favorite part is when he
goes something something epstein and
they all go oh
he goes i know he's your friend
[Laughter]
oh wow these are heroes [ __ ] you you all
loved harvey 10 years ago you all love
this guy you love epstein get out of
here
yeah i mean i'm sure most of them didn't
know to the extent of what charlie was
doing because that's like
yeah i think like you you when you hear
murmurs you're just like
oh boy like harvey is like a [ __ ] bad
human being
like that it's like crazy it is it is
weird to see that like he's like falling
apart in prison
that's crazy to go from being like the
most revered producer
because he's like man that guy's a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] but he was a good
producer
the movies are amazing and i think he
had a lot of influence on like the cuts
and like
it's funny i was rewatching entourage on
the road just going like i just need to
pick me up i just need like a [ __ ]
silly kind i love entourage yeah and but
there's a character who's
who's i think it's called wineguard oh
is he
he's like a fat guy who's like a genius
producer is he
is he a [ __ ] bag in the in the show
he's a [ __ ] bag but they keep kind of
[ __ ] him over so his outbursts are
like
semi-warranted i see but uh yeah i mean
it's
he was like you're like this is
weinstein it's crazy that was his
influence
yeah that he's in a show about showbiz i
mean ari gold is our emanuel you know
who's that
rahm emanuel's brother who's like the
guy at william morris really yeah
rahm emanuel is a beast yeah i mean i've
just seen cl i don't know anything about
his politics but i've seen clips and
you're like wow this guy is a lot of
people in chicago hate him oh really
yeah i don't know anything about
what he does or who i just he can he
could talk man he's
a family is successful yeah yeah they
are
charismatic and quippy and fun
and exhilarating to watch yeah i mean
it is it is crazy i i mean watching that
show it is hilarious too much stuff that
like won't fly anymore you're like this
must have been offensive 15 years ago
what's that i mean ari is like the good
guy on that show
there were lines where he's like quick
blow job before he was alive
like jesus christ right right yeah fun
show that was when hbo was like
going for it you know they had curb and
they had that they still have curve
that's true that's true but uh i feel
like hbo was really
cooking for a while i mean it was
definitely the premier channel it's like
six feet under sopranos those shows
[ __ ] suck though now
that's what i'm saying back then they
were like it's not just hbo it's
everywhere
everywhere i mean everyone's playing
it's so [ __ ] safe yeah
like hbo had eastbound and down that
show talk about not playing it safe in a
comedy
like what comedies are that just balls
out
i know just all in wacky silly
offensive dirty ah it's great the good
guy doesn't have to be a good guy
yeah the protagonist can be a piece of
[ __ ] and we can be
smart enough as an audience to be like
maybe i don't need to be like this guy
but there doesn't need to be a lesson at
the end of course of course
yeah that's what i hate about the
hollywood is there
they say they're progressive and they
say they're like uh trying to be
inclusive but then they're like we can't
have a guy
smoking because that's that's bad for
the kids but
he murdered his wife right so like our
priorities are all out of whack
you know it's like when they're like we
can't show a tit but we can show you
eating a uh
a moose knuckle or a moose dick and
you're like that's way
worse but that's that's just how we were
watching oh it's like classic like
you're watching like law order svu and
you're saying the most
it's like on nbc and they're like her
body was decomposing in a dumpster after
a guy [ __ ] all over
and then they're like ooh can we say
jizz that's a little jizz is a little
offensive
don't you have a bit about it like you
can say this this terror you can show
like terrorism
and like a dead body in kuwait you know
laying on the floor but
you can't say [ __ ] yeah i did a bit
about like how
on on cnn they showed mass shooting
footage but then they bleeped the curse
word
yeah like you showed a guy murder
someone but they're like ooh
this might be a little much that's my
point like you say you care about this
but you're just going with the the where
the wind's blowing
i just love it i just love someone in
the [ __ ] control room who's just like
this might be too much you know like
should we not show it they're like no
just mute it
right right you know it's insane yeah
it's insane
i'm working on a bit now about all these
people are tweeting about how friends is
offensive
and i'm like look i get it you're trying
to be included
because it's not diverse at all not
diverse and they made fat jokes and all
this [ __ ]
and then i'm like but we have the bible
the bible is everywhere and the bible is
like rape homophobia misogyny murder
incest pedophilia and it's like yeah but
that's the bible
and you're like but this is a tv show
about made up people it's fiction
yeah ah no it's true i mean people
uh i'm just saying if you're gonna do it
do it you know
i just think the goal post has been
moved moving in at a much more rapid
pace yeah yeah it's like
at the time friends like it was a huge
hit i never thought it was
funny to be honest no it's the stupid
sick guy i think like i think some of
the actors on a great comic
matthew perry is a great comic actor
and stuff but like i never thought the
writing was good
i was always just like this is generic
horseshit yeah generic horse [ __ ] it's
mainstream people loved it i mean it was
a huge hit
but uh yeah it's not like nuanced or
interesting or or
original but it's just weird that people
like we got to take this down i'm like
these are actual real problems
you know and you're worried about this
this is what you're burning calories on
that it's just
it just feels like it's i mean we
covered this last night but it's just
it's me me me let me let me get my thing
out there because they feel so good
about themselves that's what it is
that's what it is
yeah and i think you're right we're
we're moving so fast
but there's still human nature like
humans are still egotistical they're
still
selfish they're still power hungry
and [ __ ] up and all that so like
obviously in the 50s
a black and a black guy and a white lady
couldn't get married that was illegal
so okay yeah let's change that that's
that's crazy
but you're right it's like sometimes
we're going too crazy
and then if you don't go with it you're
like you're the bad guy you're like well
well let's keep it reasonable yeah
that's the whole thing
also it's kind of like uh how about just
you know
i i just think like making new shows is
my thing like
yeah like they just they go where the
money is so it's like let's do a friends
reunion let's do a sex in the city let's
bring it
of course well guess what samantha's out
on sex in the city but how about having
a black friend this time
right yeah you can you can always either
expand on an old universe
or maybe you [ __ ] make a new show
like i saw they're doing
another like willy wonka movie with
timothy how about some [ __ ]
originality
how about an original script in
hollywood like you know
i think about the lack of originality
and like how hard it is to sell
something that isn't already like a
proven like
like no one wants to make a superhero
thing unless it's marvel or dc
of course so they're like let's get
another character from dc because we
have a deal with dc and you're like
so there's you act like you want
originality but you just want
oh what you already have a deal with
like corporate strangulation
has killed originality we would never
get a pulp fiction
now i don't think so never or like even
my big fat greek wedding which was just
some lady who wrote a script
and it was funny and it got somebody
happened to take a shot on it and
produce it and then boom we got this
great comedy and good for her
but i don't know if that's no one's
going to take a chance now what are you
crazy
it's too risky but that's what art was
supposed to be
and then they come after art you're like
wait some guy makes a crazy comedy
special we're like ah that's offense we
gotta wear
like really come on oh yeah i mean it's
hilarious the [ __ ] they complain about
and then
but then also by the other side of it
like it annoys me when people that are
so [ __ ] famous complete complain
about like censorship and like i'm like
you're doing fine you're [ __ ] okay
but i did you see chris rock came out
and said something yeah i like
i thought what he said was accurate what
rock said was
um that the lack of risk that these
companies are taking
are hurting entertainment and yes i feel
like that's exactly what we're saying i
mean it's kind of like
i agree but he i read every comment
because i'm a psycho and he got he got a
ton of backlash and you're like
well first of all you're proving his
point because he's saying this and
you're like no
shut up you boomer you're out of touch
you don't know what's what it's like
well maybe hey we listened to the uh fat
phobic lady who felt threatened maybe
can we listen to him how come he can't
be threatened you know he's feeling
threatened by this he's
an expert at making provocative comedy
you know yes i mean billy crystal got a
ton of [ __ ] i said he got a ton of [ __ ]
but he said comedy's a landmine now and
it's kind of like people like you
old man it's like oh all of you were
[ __ ] upset
yeah point point proven point proven
exactly you can't see that you can't
even [ __ ] you you old man it's like
he's old yeah like that's that's the end
like he isn't
it's funny when people are like the most
sensitive group and they're like
you old piece of [ __ ] i'm like well the
elderly are a group and that's aegis
i'm not saying he's elderly i'm just
saying he's an older man now it's like
he can't have a [ __ ] opinion
i know i know i've never been a big
billy crystal guy and i'm [ __ ]
defending him
i'm not either but like he's a real dick
oh really
i've funny i've had like three
bartenders be like he's a dick oh
interesting
well [ __ ] him [ __ ] curly's goals
my friend pete horry wrote a really good
movie with him uh it was i forgot the
name of it
it's harry pull this up it's it's pete
horry billy crystal and ben schwartz is
great in it
it's it's called standing up falling
down i've never heard it he's a stand-up
in it but it's really
solid and my friend pete is a great
writer and uh
check it out if you haven't seen it
really nice it's like a dramedy but it's
got a ton of heart and it's okay
it's a lot of and billy crystal's
[ __ ] grading it
he's a talent i mean mr saturday night
is awesome never saw it oh
you got to watch that that's a great
movie and harry met sally great
so great yeah the city slickers was
great analyze this is great i mean he's
he's a he's a pro
yeah but my point is he came out and was
like this is where rowan atkinson was
like hey i just yeah i get nervous now
doing comedy and everybody's like shut
up mr bean what the [ __ ] do you know and
it's like you know it's bad when a guy
who doesn't speak
is like shit's getting bad and it's like
why can't we acknowledge that he feels
this way
offensive mime yeah yeah yeah he's like
you know cancelled right but i just
don't get like we were so worried about
someone else feeling
i'm not where's my safe space i feel
threatened i was like well why can't
they have a feeling
and we we just go ah you're old you're
white you're you're
you're dumb i don't know let's include
let's be inclusive
i think when someone like rock says that
comedy is getting
and he didn't say just comedy i think
his whole thing was entertainment he was
getting bored
i mean i'm a big believer in that not
everything you see should make you feel
great
sure i mean i agree i mean that's like
it's crazy to me
yeah i just think so much entertainment
is so safe now and part of it is the
people you pitch shows to
those offices are so hilariously
politically correct
that you can't pitch an anti-hero
anymore no no
god no archie bunker is like the
ultimate
piece of [ __ ] unlikable guy but that's
why it was a good show
right now you have a focus group and go
i didn't like that guy he was uh
he was mean all right get rid of archie
bunker but he's the whole backbone of it
archie bunker's offensive and it's just
[ __ ] uh
rob reiner on the show now yeah he's
just about a hippie just meathead yeah
exactly
um i don't know it's just donald glover
said the same thing and then everybody
attacked him it's like
maybe we're onto something maybe there's
something cooking here i don't know call
me crazy but i think there's a mom
mentality problem in this country
get it that's a great way to put it
and look and everybody's like what are
you guys all right like no we just want
fun cool crazy movies and original [ __ ]
that's all we want and also you can
write a bad character without endorsing
the views of that character
i mean it's hilarious to me that people
are like you can't
have this evil character so everyone's
got to be self-righteous in doing the
lord's work
i guess every movie is going to be an
aaron sorkin movie from now on
you can't handle sorkin yeah
it's it's it's a weird time and then
thank god for the internet as much as i
[ __ ] i'm like we're lucky we have
uh you know you put your special on
there we can we can put videos on there
and that's also where the people [ __ ] on
us so it's got it all baby we got it all
and look you're allowed to hate us and
and not like us and whatever but just
watch something else that's that's
that's a good system
yeah there's no it's funny that that's
an attitude i've never understood is
like the
outrage and the and then the stain on
that
channel you know what i mean yeah you're
furious but now you're putting all your
energy into just hating something i'm
like
yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] i hate i
don't just i don't go directly to the
creator and be like
you [ __ ] suck yeah exactly or you're
a bad person that's
that's because people go hey you make
something people are allowed to [ __ ] on
i'm like i get it but
you can't call me a a racist or
something like that's hurting my career
now you're hurting my livelihood
and you don't know me so you're saying i
made a joke in attempt i made a black
joke
attempting to be funny you called me
this horrible thing directly
how much worse would it be though if
trolls did try to get to know you you're
like [ __ ] now i gotta spend time with
this guy before he hates me
think i made this exact point last night
so we got to move on all right let's do
a bit man
all right all right i got uh i got
nothing what are you you you got some
stuff cooking
i have an idea tell me if there's
anything it's like so there are these
people that go door to door
now to convince you to take the vaccine
oh really which like you know it's just
like pathetic that we have this
scientific breakthrough in an insane
amount of time
and we have to we have to convince
people like like jehovah's witnesses to
get on board
but there's something amazing about that
to me that like and these people won't
take it because they think it has
tracking devices in it the vaccine which
is like
well we found you at uh on a wednesday
afternoon so you're not exactly jason
bourne
that's great that's great yeah we're
gonna find you anyway
yeah you know and also i used to sell
knives door-to-door i was on cutco
oh yeah i remember that yeah i tried
that for like a minute where i did the
cold calls
oh it's a nightmare it's a nightmare but
yeah that's such a great point we could
find you we have the internet we have
google maps we have geo tracking and
you're worried about this [ __ ]
vaccine that could potentially save you
yeah that's funny people people don't
want to take that vaccine
yeah you know it's weird because they
would take the flu shot and they would
take a polio
i think a lot of them don't take the flu
shot oh really i think a lot i don't
think a lot of people get the flu
i've never gotten it really yeah i get
every year oh really
i mean it's i just don't want to be sick
on the road i think it's weird if you
travel to not get it
i just never get the flu yeah i don't
know maybe you just have a better immune
system than me
which i don't know how with how much you
drink i don't know yeah
i played and literally played in dirt as
a kid i think that helped me
yeah that was the old carlin bit we used
to swim in raw
sewage tempered and raw [ __ ]
yeah that was great classic you know
what i do with my hands after i
wait what does he say i uh i said
after i take a [ __ ] do i wash my hands
no i [ __ ] on them what is it
oh [ __ ] i'll eat a hot dog off the
ground in a soccer right in calcutta
oh you know when i wash my hands when i
[ __ ] on them that was it that's
hilarious
yeah i butchered it
is this a horrible bit i'm talking about
how like rich people are and how
like uh oh you're sticking with this one
well this is a different thing it's a
different thing but like we got it
pretty good
like even poor people have a flat screen
they got a phone they got
they got a car but the explaining a
peloton
to a third world country poor person
is wacky must be so wacky like all right
you paid 1200 bucks for a bicycle and
i'm like you got that right it's a great
bicycle
well it must be pretty fast then
actually it goes nowhere
well does it power your home no no it
burns off food that i eat
i eat i eat so much food i got to burn
it off and they're like wait why would
you want to burn off food you'll die
and they're like cuz i'm trying to look
good i don't know
how does it look like power uh
electricity do you know what that is
right right we have this uh the thing
that lights up a room
yeah yeah yeah it's just crazy like
we're spending this thing
so much money on a bike that doesn't go
anywhere
yeah we'll see there's something there
just our exercise
like we have we are so privileged that
we have to work out
how privileged we are right we're eating
so much
great food that you got to burn it off
like they just work they work and like
you know
do labor and burn off that's their
exercise so they don't have to exercise
yeah have you ever seen like a farmer
type guy where you're just like oh [ __ ]
they don't they're just like an overall
shredded
yeah your workout is part of your job
right i sit at a desk all day yeah i
need to [ __ ]
sit on a bike yeah and their privilege
like i finished my work day i have a
cold beer
i eat some some meat or whatever and
they try to get a good night's sleep
we're like
uh i sat on my ass all day i watched
netflix i ate
you know take out so i got to burn this
off
and it's and not only do you sit on this
bike
but you have to you have a lady on a
screen going
work it girl come on you know like you
need motivation to do [ __ ] they probably
need that for their uh for their
manual labor job yeah oh god that's
funny they're putting their phone
together
just grab that screen you can do it yeah
you're special you go girl you don't
need no man they're like
putting together an iphone it's like a
12 year old girl
that might be too dark but that's it
that's good could be something there
could be something there yeah maybe i
don't know have people done that that
i don't know type of bit have you heard
it i haven't heard it all right all
right
i think i feel like i've heard the uh
what uh
i use electricity what's electricity
yeah yeah don't use that but i think the
thing about the motivating and
in the [ __ ] that's a good angle
that's something that's a good take
yeah what do what did he do two hours
how long was that
matt uh oh like an hour or twenty oh
okay okay that's fair
that's fair we should plug gigs yes what
do you got cooking
uh i got
atlantic city this this friday and
saturday i believe that's when this
comes out
i got tampa side splitters uh the
following thursday through saturday
i got uh raleigh good nights the one
after that
i got a bunch of other ones coming up i
got madison coming up
i got the best string of gigs of all
time oklahoma city bricktown
that's a good room i got nashville
zaney's coming up oh it's a great room
governor's in levittown we had a drop
off i was at the knicks game the other
night though and a guy and a guy was
like we'll be a governor
i love that and then and then i got
comedy off broadway kentucky i got just
a boardroom
great classic atlanta atlanta oh that's
not till september sorry
i got i got a lot coming up i'll tell
you kansas city
uh in august uh comedy club of kansas
oh i don't know that one it's in
missouri it's new it's supposed to be
good oh okay great uh
yeah all all these available
samurail.com
shows i can't wait to see on the road uh
and uh you know
by the way just before we even say
anything else this studio has been great
to us we're so grateful for it matt
gotham studios you guys are the best uh
really appreciated happy that happy we
got a home here for yeah
we might be drunk you're here uh i love
the room love mad love the studio
love the space it looks great it feels
great it feels like home goddamn it
except for the charging and if you want
to send weird packages to us
this is the place yeah yeah we've gotten
a few already so send us some liquor
send us a booze gotham
gotham studios uh send us anything 38th
street
yeah don't send it to gotham comedy club
no no no no although we might still get
it there
that's true yeah i'm there where are you
gonna be man uh
all kinds of fun stuff virginia beach
funny bone never been to virginia beach
never done the club pretty excited about
that um
orlando improv which i didn't know they
had an improv
i feel horrible uh never been there i
think it's supposed to be good
didn't you play that club back in the
day never did orlando improv i thought
you isn't like hard rock
or something i thought you did i've
opened for people at big
sean patton likes that club a lot oh
really yeah okay great i love patton
check him out san antonio the rock box
i'm trying to dabble in some rock clubs
uh portland helium uh well i'm there in
august too i love i love portland
love portland funny bone in uh toledo
that could be never done it but that
could be enough shitty i did it i
featured there like back in the day
for who lisa landry whoa 2011 i think
oh wow i forgot about lisa from been a
while we had we saw the plan at the
eighth movie she was a fun hank she's
cool she drinks
yeah yeah houston improv that's a big
room philly helium all kinds of fun
stuff buffalo helium
dayton funny bone appleton skyline
arlington improv so yeah a lot of fun
dates markdown
comedy.com uh check out our specials
we're all over youtube give us some
clicks give us a comment for the aligo
and uh rex peeves we might be drunk pod
at gmail send us a drink a movie you
like
a peeve a joke whatever you got we'll
take it we'll read them on the patreon
patreon.com we might be drunk pod
yes tell a friend spread the love spread
the cheeks
we'll see on the road folks thanks again
gotham all right